foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
strategies for epidemics containment in
the context of the anthropocins planet
degradation this webinar is part of the
microbiology virtual week and I'm Susie
Valdez of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab Roots so let's get started before we
begin I want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to First participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation now you can find that live
chat located on the right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you want during
this presentation to do so simply type
them into the ask a question box and
click submit we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation simply click
on that help desk button located at the
bottom of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally as a reminder this presentation
is educational and offers free
continuing education credit click on
that continuing education credits link
located in the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits I now
present to these speaker Dr Francisco
vez research director and professor at
the French Research Institute of
development at Montpellier University
for a complete biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen Dr Baez welcome you
may now begin your presentation sir
okay first of all let me thank you this
opportunity to share some ideas and some
results that we have generated during
this covered epidemic uh let's go for uh
sorry let's go for the title
here then the strategies for epidemic
containment in the context of
anthropocene Planet degradation as
everyone knows we are
following a
temperature elevation of the planet and
then and many others affects generated
by humans this is because I'm talking
about anthropocene which is a period
compressor
from uh 200 years ago at the beginning
of in virtualization and now
um because research or all whatever be
the activity activity that we can do
uh medical activities uh agricultural
activities and so on whatever
every everything is uh
must be is be done it's been done in in
a particular context
in people that works in tropical
environments or other environments
whatever in the U.S in Europe and then
all of us in the planet are are
submitted to this context then this is
because I wanted to talk about this uh
this first
slide with this particular title now
let's go to a part of introduction just
to continue to talk about uh about that
then the planetary context it's uh as
follows We are following a high pressure
and Rapid loss of life uh living beings
let's say uh even geographical
geophysical change for example
ecosystems uh biodiversity human
demography this all all of these aspects
are changing our planet
uh for example here on the on the top uh
right of the slide we have a simple
comparison between
uh popular human population in
18 uh 100 and uh now uh
2050. then we have a difference of 10 1
billion in 18 000 and uh and
10 billions in in few years from now
then that means that we will be 10 times
more in a very short period of time
200 years let's say 250. and second we
have
uh a lack of the capacity of
international Healthcare Community to
provide efficient timely response to
infectious Outlet this is the situation
you can see in the in the figure uh on
the top uh on the bottom
a right of the slide
well numerous
outbreaks
including Ebola
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
responses to re-emerging pathogens
or emerging new emerging pathogens we
need to think to act in a totally
integrative way
to consider always the whole planetary
infectious context this is the situation
that we are
living now and then our
our idea is to provide efficient
efficient Solutions through conceptual
and technological properties
as well as obviously an accurate
surveillance
uh of these patents then these needs
heavy investments in particular at risk
on at-risk approaches
in order to rapidly explore innovative
solutions
as a scientists did for RNA vaccinations
a vaccine against sarskov II this was
very rapid response very good
uh even is if not a sort of Panacea the
solution it is permitted to the human
population to
to control the
the this epidemic uh as uh as much as we
we could
then for for
carry out their surveillance we need
obviously clinicians veterinarians and
environmental actors in the field
as well as a efficient Ultra sensitive
for early detection
detection in order to adopt adaptive
cultural measures in particular for
example for this kind of diseases like
Ebola monkeypox now uh the uh to detect
uh also residual viral laws in in
comparison individuals
that could uh
re-initiate
an epidemic this is then it is important
to detect very early
to stop the
the the the spread of the
viruses or or pathogens in general
uh on the uh obviously residual viral
loads in a way to be sure that people
are free of uh pathogens to be released
in the nature let's say
okay
then uh from this situation
I think that we can discuss about the
fact that we need uh to to learn some
some lessons from the this so zoonotic
uh uh Sask of two covet pandemic
in multiple cases of infectious disease
outbreaks uh human has uh indirect or
direct
uh
responsibility
for example uh through the Intensive
animal farming for human concept
consumption
a massive of or rare or protected
animals for human consumptions illegal
in particular in where wet markets
markets in in Asia or in Africa this is
very frequent
uh or another different reason is poorly
Justified as zardo's creation of
pathogens with gain of function
totally ignoring in this case
consequence and
obviously the mitigations needed to stop
what the these researchers could create
uh I will uh explain a little bit with
some examples here for example the pig
farming has generated in 2009
flu uh H1N1 outbreak that took only six
months to spread to spread from Mexico
to the whole planet
uh by chance this was a low moderate
transmission low pathogenesis and then
the epidemic stopped six months later
uh another case of poultry farming uh in
this case was the
avian through
uh highly pathogenic one that was
killing some humans not that much by
chance 800.
uh all over the world
um but the point here that this uh
these virus was
transformed to gain function to uh for a
higher transmission among mammals
that mean among among humans
and this was done by a
European researchers researchers in in
Netherlands
and then because they published this
data in science then they they generate
the idea to other researchers in China
to generate more than 100 of H5 and 1
and H7 and 9. and then that means that
we have in in the fridge in somewhere
very dangerous uh viruses that could
escape from those uh places
by accident or whatever be the reason
and the last example is such coronavirus
variance of concern that mean Alpha
without
Omicron
ba5 and so on different variants
that were already originated from Yuan
and China respiratory virus with high
transmission capacity
the problem that we have here is that
Chinese Healthcare authorities didn't
timely transmitted critical information
to who in order to adopt mitigation
control measures and this is the kind of
thing that we can we need to avoid in
the future
uh despite the code driven International
in let's say incomplete investigation in
last year
uh we lack lab box electronic data where
uh erase it for more than two years that
means now we don't know we still ignore
the virus origin and this is a problem
because
uh when we have more information we have
more tools we can develop to better
respond to this kind of outbreaks
uh uh as consequence discovered 19 has
generated over
6.5 billion human deaths
[Music]
600 millions of direct victims by chance
most of them uh recovered with uh
because this is a let's say a nice virus
is not so pathogenic despite all the
cases that we know
uh uncovered as massively impacted also
uh socioeconomic aspects and generated
dozens of trillions of dollars of uh
a use for the worldwide economies then
the impact of these uh such Corona
saskarona too has been uh quite uh
strong in economical terms
thanks to the first historical severe
prolonged worldwide lockdown of human
populations this has generated a
Dramatical decrease of human activities
during this period
then from that we have two kind of
effects positive effect and negative
effect
uh indirect highly positive effect of
covet
on the health of the planet
we see unprecedented decrease of
manufacturing manufacturing mining
agriculture fishing
Transportation pollution including
plastic fossil resources stocks is the
gases
uh noise and Light
uh we had also the possibility to see
that a daily decrease of fossil
dioxide carbon emissions that were
reduced by minus 17 percent
that was compiled at the the levels of
2006.
uh very very important then and in in
2020 the growth rates of the global
population fell under one percent per
year
this is have never seen uh since uh
1950. then these are let's say positive
effects and we can see on the right side
a photograph a satellite photograph uh
to detect the uh
[Music]
nitrogen
um
dioxide nitrogen sorry in China in the
region of
in the region of
on the east of China
and then we can see that before in
January before the
the the lockdown you have an intensive
uh presence of uh
this uh nitrogen dioxide in contrast
soon after the the start of the lockdown
you have immediately uh almost nothing
then that mean that the toxic gases can
disappear very quickly
and then this is another very positive
effect
as negative effect we can see that
poaching was one of the negative effects
in Africa and Asia that reduced
biodiversity they
were chasing pangolins rhinos elephant
for Chinese markets and otherwise animal
for food then the markets and food
because they were lacking food because
of of the lockdown then these are
negative effects
then let's move let me show you some
approaches to better prepare
surveillance of low emerging diseases in
order to
better uh adopt adapted
cancer measures
then
let me show to to do that working on SAS
we have
demonstrated that Ultra sensitive
detection of pathogens is mandatory for
an efficient surveillance
to early contain pathogen transmission
reduce false negative diagnosis
and they take residual viral loads in
comparison to prevent any new epidemic
ignition
one of the key strategies to reach these
objective is to realize a sample
preparation allowing pathogen
concentration period the step prior the
step
of pathogen detection using classical
PCR or rtpcr lamps Etc
to give more chances to detect low
pathogen loads in complex samples then
the sarskov 2 example will be seen here
but before
let me show how we are going how we did
to to reach this objective then we use a
protein which is called APO lipoprotein
H which is a a pleiotropic protein from
the plasma
uh belonging belonging to the innate
acute phase response this is let's say
one of those proteins like CRP which is
the most well known
uh from the first line of uh of uh
immune response in in our uh bodies
and the role of this uh protein in this
context is a sort of sensor on scavenger
of non-self then it can catch any kind
of pathogen
uh but not commensal bacteria for
example from the gut because it detect
only
a pernicious microorganisms this is a
small protein around 50 kilo kilo Dalton
um in a concentration close to 200
milligrams per liter in plasma able to
interact with high Affinity at nanomolar
scale uh
with electrostatic interactions uh
hydrophobic interaction protein protein
and then it could react with LPS from E
coli phosphatidylis Sarai from HIV hcv
and other viruses SBI or M1 from other
uh bacteria and then on the right side
you have the
let's say a representation of the
structure of this protein with five
regions showing different uh different
regions that could react with different
molecules like LPS or another
uh for strategic terrain Etc and then we
are able now to produce these uh
delivered peptides that mimic the aphoh
functions and then uh these maybe this
uh
mimetic peptides from a4h are able to to
interact with all these pathogens as uh
as is as needed then what we do is to
put these peptides on to coat let's say
surfaces or magnetic beads or membranes
or chips that
will be used to to concentrate uh the
pathogens uh before to be detected I
will show you how
let me go here
uh uh then you can see on the right on
the left side of your screen
the Beats on the upper side of the tube
coated with APO H peptides and the tube
containing pathogens viruses or or
bacteria whatever and then what we do is
put these beads into the sample complex
samples can be serum
um
um saliva any any biological or
environmental sample then we agitate for
few minutes
and then we apply a magnet that will
catch the magnetic beads that has
already captured and uh we are we are
going to concentrate and this following
step
by precipitating all the bits that has
the viruses captures once we are in this
uh step we are ready to detect what we
want to detect we can sequence we can do
PCR or we can isolate by cultivating
this uh this
capture
pathogens we can use any kind of
detection system for example
bioluminescence or bacteria etc etc
then this is a very simple way to
concentrate
prior the detection that giving us the
opportunity to detect very low uh viral
loads or bacterial lobes from a complex
sample
and then if I move correctly and then
this is an example where we did an
isolation of Hunter virus from Andes
um highly pathogenic respiratory virus
as you can see we isolated this train
one and string two the new isolated
strains
as compared with a
uh
on the left you have
the phase contrast on the microscope a
um
an antibody that recognize only the
end protein
of the virus and then on the right side
you have the the nucleus of the cells
then you can see that the elapsed
framework was perfectly captured
on the where we in the absence of the
virus we cannot see the green the green
color
uh in contrast we can obviously can see
the new isolated strains one and two
using this procedure
um I can show you also another aspect
that this need we need to know is up
apho H bind and capture
only infectious
non-self in this case viruses this is
the case of dengue then when we did an
experiment where we took the sample and
we took the sample normally and the the
other example was heated
when I was at 56 degrees and then uh we
we are able to denaturate the surface of
the Dengue virus then we when we proceed
to the dilution of this virus here in
the graph
and the different situations in the
presence in the absence of a poet is in
blue or in the presence of apho H we can
see that we catch everything when we
don't dilute the sample or we dilute
only let's say 10 times 100 times 1000
times Etc
and we can see that uh
we are able to detect at highest
dilutions only viruses with apho h are
not without Hindu here in Gray
and obviously viruses that were uh
denaturated we were not able to be
detected at the highest dilutions
then this is an important uh
aspect to know because what we need for
to to carry out this kind of
Technologies is to
[Music]
to have high quality samples for example
samples that are fizzy and so many times
many cycles are not adapted for this
kind of studies
oh sorry
uh
here I can show you what we observed in
the case of hepatitis C at the hospital
from negative uh 25 negative samples
that were suspected to have
uh but ITC and then in the hospital they
realized that one of the reference uh
detection system using kovas are tpcr
for hcv they detected zero positive in
those suspected uh samples
instead they found obviously 25
negatives because they were only
suspected under the the kobas was
negative instead of that APO h plus this
RT PCR
we were able to detect eleven uh of out
of this 25
that means that we are
avoiding these false negatives and this
is very important to adopt the proper
cancer measures or treatments or
whatever we want to do with those
patients then has direct consequence for
the patients
the false negatives
here we did something uh
comparable but this time with ebola and
then you can see here the samples
here you can see that the normal
detection down with the Arctic
qpcr owned by
use and read with their own FDA
approvement
diagnostic there are where
one sample negative that were positive
when we use the a4h systems moreover if
you look this column as compared with
other columns we have a gain of
three uh city of amplification that
means that we have at least one log
more sensitive
detection
of Ebola and this is very important in
particular when we have we are in
presence of uh
of convalescent patients as we did here
for example
uh comparison patient that we were
having rates because we did sequence and
PCR we had three logs different
um difference and the moreover doing
sequencing we were not only to detect uh
Ebola but also some co-infections with
NASA virus which is a confounding
hemorrhagic Factor
uh then you you know the I want to to
show you that the way to pray uh
concentrate uh low wider loads that are
not detected with the current uh
existing reference systems is a very
important uh manner to better control
epidemics and better manage the patient
treatments
and when we did some environmental fluid
detection
we can see that in the prince in the
process of a poetic hearing
in in pink uh we had have a difference
uh
one thousand times the the sensitivity
to detect weeds with a pH as compared
with no with the absence of a poetry
here much more almost uh one thousand
times because we go from sometimes from
zero to 1 million or
1000 to 1 million then you know the
enrichment is considerable
here very quickly the same for influenza
virus I don't want to bother you too
much just show you that whatever be the
the
[Music]
dilution here I don't know what happened
with the
okay sorry okay here are delusion 10 to
10 then you can see that uh with with a
poetry we can really be much more
sensitive to detect any kind of virus
and some one example very short with the
sepsis bacteria this is a staphylococcus
aureus
that where we would show they that
actually only in
half a day
uh and uh able to detect
uh in 5 ml of whole blood
uh only once say a few one Colony
forming unit of bacteria by PCR these
restaurants were confirmed with the
larger
[Music]
um cohorts by Siemens that published
this data uh several years ago and then
you can see that this this system works
for uh many uh type of viruses or
bacteria
in the case of sepsis this is very
important because it's a one of medical
emergencies that need to be
treated very very rapidly otherwise the
patient can die and then the we need to
provide to these patients and
appropriate
antibiotic
strategy then the next is just to show
you that many bacteria we can work with
many bacteria including some bacteria
here as trophyllma quite play in the in
the right side in the bottom which is a
bacteria that is very difficult to
cultivate it takes 15 days it can be
detected within a few hours when we
treat with this aphoh system
uh let me then show you what we did with
uh very rapidly with Kobe using this
system
we
taking the the property of concentration
of this um
of these uh aphoh
and the viruses we use it at
non-invasive invasive and
self-collectible sampling
foreign sensitive detection using
article PCR
then if we move we can see that this is
the the process
we can collect different oral gargle
nozzle uh
um
sampling
at home some of them or in the hospital
for others then we use the system
magnetic base with a pH
and we
the gardens were
treated for example with 10 mL of water
that we are put in presence of
with the Beats we for five minutes
agitation and then the separation with
Magnetic system and then the
concentration just before the PCR that
is being done here and then using this
oh sorry
using this protocol
we can see here in the next uh for 85
persons in the clinical trial we have
shown that the red component with blue
with blue is without a poet here is with
a poetry then whatever be the gene that
you are using to detect the virus always
is in favor of apho H with a very
important gain of of sensitivity almost
always 10 times
in addition you can see the gray Zone
where the the virus are not detected in
with the blue system that the normal PCR
let's say
they are always detected with uh with a
poets
that mean that we can face the
um
the fast negative generator but the
normal the normal
detection manner
then if I move to the next
and then here the most important is to
show that this uh this approach works
for all the variants of concern here we
work with alpha beta and gamma then you
can see with 8.h is much better with
that that without Ingress
and the next is very interesting because
I will show you a follow-up uh in three
patients where one was positive at the
hospital and then we did the follow-up
with the system apoge it was always
positive and always gaining three a two
to three City some time more and then
this was also a possibly that was
followed at up to the end of the
infection and this was negative at the
hospital the different days then this is
a false negative because it was positive
with the airport and that that's that's
it for this uh system that uh apoge is a
unviral concentration
when we use non-invasive can be very
useful to
for Ultra sensitive detection sometimes
10 times better than the rtpcr alone
we reduce the false negative as I told
you this is simple rapid and well
adapted for Diagnostic in children that
don't like the nasopharyngeal approach
or or persons that need repeated virus
control in the hospital for example
this can be easily used as I said also
with isothermal amplification not only
PCR and then what we are doing right now
is sequencing and can be used as I
showed you before like a motor of these
companies
now we are presently working in Aureus
detection system concept which is
uh means Ambassador rapid ultrasensitive
detection kit
to adapt to different panels of
pathogens Circle monkey pox bacteria
whatever
that mean
a test that can be done very sensitive
way very rapid in less than half an hour
then this is a sort of solution for what
is coming because of the situation of
the planet we are going to lack water
and the situation will be highly
degradated then we need to uh face the
next uh outbreaks with the simple rapid
and efficient Solutions now we have some
let's say sometimes to act and we have a
lot of means but because the situation
would be degraded then we need to think
about new Solutions
let's move to the the end of the
of this talk let me talk to you very
quickly about the the global context
that we are following
then the what we see the big story of
complexity from The Big Bang up to the
position of life four billions years ago
now we are in the anthropocent that
started two centuries ago then this
anthropocene is clearly impacting
severely impacting the planetary
planetary geophysical and living
conditions geophysical because of the
water because the the temperatures
because the
polar carrots uh that are being
uh throwing uh
multiplication parameters undergo
radical changes in particular in these
last 40 years we can see that we have
lost simply lost 70 percent of
vertebrates eight percent of
insects and 50 of vertebrates of sorry
Birds and all the rest 30 percent 20
percent of the 50 percent are in
extinctional ways uh in particular due
to poaching and
Industrial fishing
Etc multiple human activities negatively
impact the the ecosystem include the
extraction and use of natural enforcing
resources mega fires that we know in in
several places of the world in Amazon
where man create these mega fires
uh
weak pollution we we reduce the natural
ecosystem habitats Wetlands mangroves
last year polar cups rivers lakes and we
know everything here in Colorado either
Colorado River you know that is
suffering uh
a severe growth now
then moreover we are increasing the
terrestrial and ocean temperatures
mainly due to dioxide carbon and methane
all these data are correlated with
uncontrolled demographic growth
since 20th century reaching the we are
reaching the 8 billion humans now this
year as compared with only
a single billion in
uh in the uh the beginning of uh
19th century
uh but the point is that if we compare
2022 we
um
[Music]
1800 ER one human from now
use a lot of resources
as compared with a human in in in 18 uh
100. uh
then because this these correspond to
1 000 times
more environmental impact we are
now as compared with the people to to
centuries ago we are not
eight billions but we are a trillions of
humans in in terms of consumers
and then you can see the impact that we
could we could have or we have we are
having on the planet this is the one of
the contexts
um and this was the increase of the
population was uh due to the
the antibiotics that were used in uh
after the second world war even if they
were discovered
very early before
uh because you know vaccines therapeutic
strategies
um and this has contributed to
unprecedented demographic growth
then um
then this is a paradox of the medical
progress that that could accelerate by
the way the planet degradation
then we need to to find Solutions we
need to be more intelligent that we are
now
uh because the this situation is making
that pathogens are concentrated
concentrating in highly dense
promiscuous habitants
in increasing the Civility and frequency
of of epidemics then you see the context
impact the consequence
and then if you know in the
governmental panel for Climate Change
ipcc Report 22 they show us that
um
oh sorry oh
that the impacts on climate change are
observing in many ecosystems and human
systems as you can see here I high or
very high impact on changes of ecosystem
ecosystem structures whatever be the
place African Antarctic Etc you can see
that everything is negative in fresh
water uh production or oceans is always
negative the species range is shifts the
rest your freshwater oceans on this
species also the the impact is very
negative you know in that blue here
uh changes in timing then terrestrial
this is the cycle of those
ecosystems then everything is being
impacted highly negative because of uh
the Human Action here observe impacts on
of climate change on human system impact
on water scarcity and food production
then everything is a negative or for the
moment uh we cannot see if there are
some sometimes a little bit positive
aspect but most of them are negative as
you can see
fishing production poultry Etc
and then impact on the uh infectious
diseases infectious diseases there will
be more and more and so on I don't you
you can see this in the in the ipcc
report that is available on the online
and then they propose the uh the this
graph that show us uh all the negative
aspects that we can see and some
possibilities to uh for resilient
restoration of living conditions if we
do act quickly on with different aspects
that I will show you here in the next
to uh you can see that we can maybe uh
keep the temperature
below 2 degrees 2 degrees for the mean
of the planets will induce
pray these things totally crazy things
as with this report is uh is reporting
then some examples to make positive but
we need to be active right now
immediately no room to waste time
first of all we need to learn and train
designers and broadcasting media because
they ignore most of the things that we
are talking about
to calculate the real price of things
considering the huge nature added value
for example water
there are companies that use uh billions
liters of water to produce for example
Coca-Cola Pepsi or whatever
producers of water they they use and
pollute a lot of water that they don't
pay the price
they could we need to create new jobs
breathing with restoration and
resilience of ecosystems for young
people all people whatever everyone can
not need to be involved we need to
reduce the uh World populations with
policies reduce infertility reduce
Transportation with fossil analysis
around the world
we're used to three tones
of CO2 per individual because in France
for example we call some in the mean is
11 and a half tons per individual in
France then we need to reduce almost by
20 80 percent
we need to replace all the fossil
energies we we know something here in
Europe because of the uh War
um
in in
uh in Europe
Russia and Croatia sorry
the the Russian war
uh and the one important and easy thing
that we need to do is to plan
1.2 trillion trees
in addition to existing three billions
to three trillion sorry not billions
three trillions to to restore the other
three trillions that we destroyed
already
uh to both This 1.2 trillion trees will
absorb almost all the exceeding uh of
carbon dioxide for the next 10 years and
save essential strategy pretty species
to maintain life on the planet these are
simple some some of them are simple
things to be done
uh others are not so simple but we can
do that
[Music]
I again my on my I don't know if you can
see
this screen
I have a big screen on my on my computer
uh then conclusion
the pandemic experience must learn
something and then we must listen this
experience
we have a lot of consequence of this
anthropocene sixth mass extinction that
we discussed already
despite multiple artists that has been
provided by great thinkers expressions
the French naturalist on Humbert
Alexander in 18th century The Economist
Thomas Martins in 18th century
Paul and uh an early from the last
century and right now they are continue
to alert about that
philosophers from the 16th and 17th
centuries Espinoza
uh Freddie niche
in the 19th century including
volcanologists
astrophysicians
that started with Copernicus balileo
Galilei from Florence called Sagan
origin in France and now in present that
all of them tell us hey guys move ahead
against this uh this the catastrophic
context that we are living
by
contrast and
we were unlucky to have this the car
that the characters in France since the
7th Century that promoted the wrong idea
that the nature is a machine to serve
humankind
he consider humans to be at the highest
evolutionary position out of the nation
and the error is that we are in the
nature we belong together all the
ecosystem
[Music]
consequently considering the holistic
predictive context we need to accept a
maximum of intelligible information that
we can compute from different situations
Health Care Etc to rapidly generate
rational and intelligent solution
despite all the negative aspects of
coffee is is learning something to us
uh most of the infected patients there
are some positive also aspects are
asymptomatic the high majority of
symptomatic patients recover
in use low moderate mortality only one
percent
uh these acute infectious is easy to
important uh importantly be neutralize
it as compared with HIV or Dengue other
viruses for example and then using
simple or new vaccine strategies a virus
can be neutralized or as well as with
horse polygon antibodies the
neutralization is very high as you can
see in the figure on the right side uh
the serum need to be diluted between 10
to 5 or up to one million times uh for
different kinds of uh of variants
including one of the lights as well be
four and five
and uh um this is being done in in in
the framework of European project called
it epic epic ground
to Consortium
under
I will finish with this uh this Bible
has the incredible power to stop for a
few weeks the crazy race Humanity of
humanity
to go anywhere demonstrated that rapid
and substantial environmental
restoration is yet possible
in the absence of humans that most of of
human activity that most of the time are
not really needed
therefore instead to neglect and rapidly
come back to our way of life as humans
are doing
after the lockdown this planet planetary
real-time demonstration coffee
demonstration must be highly highly be
considerate as a guide
to rapidly start
to restore our wonderful Oikos I mean
planet our wonderful home let's say in
Greek for his destruction resulting from
the rigor dependence of our brains
via the striatum dopamine axis we can
talk about that if you want for some
questions
discover I want to
um
I want to point out that these covers
discover discover something
we are a rational intuitive or
counterintuitive thinking like Galileo
or Einstein
or simply by facing certain DPT
situations this ladder is only possible
is the if the discovery is able to see
the Eureka moment due to the
analogic capacity of the brain to make
necessary connections and researching
uh deductions as did Young Fleming in
1928 who discovered penicillin from
a total unexpected situations
microwaves were discovered like in that
way Salient DPT Discovery as many others
discovered that did in that way and then
my final
comments will be consequently we cannot
ignore the covid-19 lessons and we need
to see this Eureka moment
since we need to start to set up new
existential Paladin compatible with the
beauty of life that we see the
destruction right now
thus we must plan trees as I told you 1
billion 0.2 to reduce uh CO2 and produce
O2
consume much less in general animals in
particular give more space to Wildlife
will be dilute pathogens instead instead
of Contracting concentrating them
otherwise we need to reduce demography
and blah blah Etc I would like to finish
here
despite my
huge screen
yeah thank you very much uh then I take
a question if we have time thank you I
think that I was over the time but uh
sorry for that thank you absolutely no
problem Dr vez thank you very much for
that informative presentation and we
will now start the live q a portion of
the webinar if you have any questions
please ask now just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we do have just a little
bit of time I'm going to ask one or two
questions and see if we can get them in
Dr bias our first question
can you please comment on consequences
of false negative diagnosis in covid-19
and other diseases
yes this is very common because all the
diagnostic system existing already or
which are reference diagnosis systems
FDA approved
Etc that I am talking of high quality
system of detection most of them when
when the pathogen loads is too low let's
say they are not able to detect the
presence of pathogens in the in the
samples most of the time samples are too
small uh and then
this existing tests work with very small
quantities at the most one ml at the
maximum and then obviously we need to
develop systems that are able to detect
even one pathogens per ml or per 5 ml as
we did for sepsis in whole blood and
that means that the impact is double one
for their patient if if you are
considered as a negative person then
that means that if you were infected the
doctor will tell you all okay you are
accurate already then uh feel free to
to to to to to
go and then we you will not be provided
with a adopted treatment and whatever
then this could be a permission for your
health this is for the individual and
for uh when we need to contain some
some epidemics like Ebola for example if
some patients go out of the center of
treatments of Ebola and then these
people that are in in fact not negative
but positive will spread the virus on
the population and the the epidemic will
will grow as we knew in the last big
epidemic in 2014 uh where we had a lot
of uh of contamination due to the fast
negatives
Dr Baez thank you very much for your
time today we're not going to be able to
answer any other questions what a great
presentation you have and thank you for
your important research before we go I
do want to thank our audience for
joining us today and further questions
and questions we did not have time for
today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for two years until September 8 2024 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone bye-bye